the jurogan experience first of all i
think it's amazing that no one's talked
you into doing mma
it's incredible i've been close how cool
mostly the lady outside my wife lauren
really is the one that's talked me out
of it really yeah bro like
when i graduated from college in 2011
university of nebraska
wrestling was still on the brink of
it was in its infancy of marketing and
branding and really making it a
professional career so
mma was the new kid on the block and it
was growing and expanding
and we had a lot of our guys
transitioning in henry cejudo ben askren
daniel cormier
and so i really thought about it i was
like okay i'm gonna wrestle the olympics
in london 2012.
win the gold and then i'm gonna make the
transition to mma i'll be 25 years old
i'll have plenty of time
and then i met lauren and she's like
listen you're doing well in the sport
stay
here you're comfortable this is a
different it's a different
sport mma in comparison to wrestling but
it's a good thing
it is a different sport and it also has
a lot more head trauma and there's a lot
of things to consider 100
that's what i think about all the time
listen
i think about going to mma until i see a
guy like platinum mike perry
get his whole thing split
nose crooked i'm like i'm good it's like
in wrestling you lose you get taken down
pushed out you know you get pinned and
fighting you lose you get something
broken
choked out tap you know it's unconscious
it's a very very different sport
wrestling it's much
it's a you score as many points as
possible with
doing the least damage as possible in
mma i feel like it's
it's different it's a shame that there's
not more
attention put on the professional like
like at one point in time professional
wrestling was actual wrestling
yeah yeah it wasn't like wwe
entertainment it was
professional wrestling and it was done
for
why can't they do that i know they tried
to do that a few years back
there was a an organization i think was
it kevin jackson that was doing it yeah
yeah yeah he was doing something where
he was doing
a professional wrestling organization
but it just didn't catch on for some
reason
but yet golf is on tv for sure baseball
and
all these things bags bro cornhole i was
watching the cornhole
championships on espn the other day i'm
like bro this is
wild like corn hole is on espn
more often than wrestling but isn't that
just now
because of there's no crowds and covid
and there's all the weirdness and
there's a lot of [ __ ] that's on
like if you follow sportscenter on
instagram like half the [ __ ] they do is
like people in their backyard like doing
crazy dunks and stuff
i think the the invention of the
internet has definitely changed the game
for our sport
we are in an epic time where
anyone can be famous all you need is an
iphone cell phone period like
if you can film footage and upload it
and it's
funny it's inventive it's disruptive
like
you have an audience and people are
going to follow it so people that are
going viral now becoming superstars
aren't even the most particularly
talented people in society they just
have a niche
and they know how to stay consistent
with it well sometimes it doesn't even
make sense
like something just catches like
remember the dude that was on the
skateboard
uh doing fleetwood cranberry juice
just for whatever reason everybody's
like that guy looks like he's having to
get this man a truck get him more
cranberry juice
and now he's on i look he's always on
podcasts he's all over the place
he bought a house he bought a car i mean
it's really interesting the beauty of it
yeah that's the beauty of it is it gives
people an opportunity there it is right
there yeah so it was
it was professional wrestling league
that they established and
you know when people reference what we
do i call it olympic wrestling honestly
i don't even call it professional
wrestling because
that is kind of an ode to the wwe an old
time wwf so it's a
it's a unique thing that we had at this
time this is tommy rowland's daniel
cormier both
extremely competitive both uh great
wrestlers okay one year
state this probably was around 0.405 ish
um so i was still in high school real
pro wrestling that's right so they had
different cities across the country that
had their own teams it was almost like
xfl-esque
it kind of had that vibe and you said
that's rulon gardner yeah really
gardner and who's the tim johnson in the
middle he works for the big ten network
and also for
espn he does commentary for the uh ncaa
championships yearly
and then the last guys nick carr who was
a
ncaa champ world medalist and roulon is
another guy that made the transition he
made the transition to mma did he
know that yeah yeah he fought a bunch of
times over in japan and actually
crazy i think what stopped him was he
lost a toe
in a frostbite accident he's a former
cornhusker
so we went to the same university and i
got a chance to kind of spend some time
with
but he was out when i was kind of
transitioning in and so he's an
interesting cat and he is one of those
guys that's like shrouded in this
mystery but there's so many
like epic stories about who he was what
he's done
how much he's eaten he's a gorilla dude
realizing that
the size of that guy massive man um and
then obviously him beating corellon
which is
pretty much considered the most
legendary victory in wrestling in
history
that's a weird victory right because
it's like corellon
all he did was get corellon to break his
grip yeah and it was a new rule
right yep the rules are evolving all the
time
in wrestling so it's uh one of those
rule changes
that year in particular which wasn't
it didn't translate well to the average
fan so like the
toughest thing about wrestling is that
the rules change so often that a
non-traditional wrestling fan can't
really keep up you watch a football game
you know listen you put the ball into
the end zone it's six points extra point
a point
field goal three points right safety two
you watch basketball you know if you're
behind this arc it's three points if
you're within it it's two points
in wrestling there's so many different
subjective
rule sets that you're like okay well if
you unlock your hands here or if this
guy gets pushed out of bounds it's a
point but if you shove him out of bounds
it's no point if he's grounded
it's no points but if his knees off the
mat then it's a point so there's so many
different like
little nuances in the sport that make it
difficult to follow
and even if you're within it like
sometimes you have to address what the
rule set is before you even compete in a
tournament
there are times when we're meeting with
uh administration and referees before we
compete at the olympics world
championships just so we can stay
current
on the rules set for that year because
it's just that much always evolving
always evolving that is that something
that plays in your head while you're
actually competing do you have to think
like oh wait a minute what is
what's the rule for this place you know
that's a good question i think in the
heat of the moment sometimes
i imagine you've seen it a lot in mma
whether it's a guy
you know hitting someone in the back of
the head or you know kicking them when
they're down on a knee like all these
little
things that when you're in the battle
and you're fired up and you're trying to
put this man out
like you don't even think about the rule
set you just you know
it has to be programmed i think
experience just uh
multiple times within this position
there's a certain level of savviness
and mental toughness that you have to
have to get there catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience